ben ouais
daniel boucher est une bête de scène
c'est tout à défaut de pouvoir communier
avec son public en salle
il s'est tourné vers les concerts en
ligne et ça fonctionne
il pour ces spectacles 4 jeudis de chez
nous à chez vous il a vendu près de 3500
billets et ont même décidé d'ajouter une
supplémentaire l'annulation du festival
le jeu mis dans une situation où il
fallait absolument réagir
je comprends pas qu'on a décidé de
l'essayer en fait c'est l'fun parce que
la difficulté s'est transformée en
opportunité
selon un récent sondage commandé par le
centre national des arts une personne
sur deux affirme avoir regardé un
événement culturel en ligne depuis le
début de la pandémie est un peu plus
d'une personne sur dix affirme être
prête à payer la moitié du prix d'un
billet pour un événement en ligne auquel
elle aurait autrement assister en
personne
malheureusement pour l'instant on vit
dans un monde où l'argent existe
comprend chacun où il faut charger et
recharger comme quand on voit dans une
salle depuis le début de la pandémie
le point de vente points comme aussi
s'est mis à vendre des billets pour des
concerts virtuels de gestion qui nous
permet par spectacle la syrie virtuel
propose également des concerts payants
en ligne
une façon de conserver le lien entre le
public et les artistes
la seconde qu'on a commencé à produire
les shows de vue une flandre élus
mandats or dans deux rues c'est que
c'est comme gravir en font une solution
de rechange entendre confinement mais
pas seulement
je pense que les spectacles en ligne et
les spectacles en salle et un festival
peuvent absolument cohabiter c'est comme
le disque l'enregistrement en chantant
le la musique enregistrée et la musique
vivante
[Musique]
ici la bi alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal
bahati
[Musique]